my guest this week is an author activist
and former leader of the English Defence
League
he's also no stranger to controversy
Tommy Robinson welcome to the show thank
you for having me on all right man so I
want to start with this which is what I
led the show off with which is that I
struggled with the decision to even have
you on the show
because I see what people say about you
and half of it is this guy is gonna save
the Western world and then half of it is
he's a bigot he's a racist and plenty of
other stuff in line with that so first
off do you get that often do you get
that people are sometimes afraid to talk
to you yes and there's a reason for that
you will be targeted as has anyone else
that speaks to me no great buy a
campaign you will and trust me you will
I've just been asked last night it was
released I'm going to be addressing this
the Hindu leadership of the UK I've been
invited to an event to discuss
multiculturalism they've been targeted
they're getting attacked now I expect
that when I turn up if they're not
forced or pressurised into cancelling
which is what's happened with university
after university after university with
schools anyone that asked me to speak
even TV shows in the UK there's a
conservative their effort to silence
what I'm saying and to attack anyone
that gives me a platform to say it yeah
well as I mentioned at the top that was
really what my deciding factor was to
talk to you because I'm so sick of
everyone being labeled bigoted and
racist and all that that if I'm afraid
to talk to you then that that is almost
a bigger problem than bigotry and racism
so that's why we have to do this I think
yeah you're in you're in a minority that
I so thank you you are all right well
most people will put their reputations
or their careers or or things like that
before free speech in the UK yeah well
somehow I still have this belief that if
I talk about free speech that it'll act
be good for my career we shall see but
why don't we start with this let's just
start with the most obvious piece of
meat are you bigoted against Muslims god
no I try to separate Muslims whenever I
did whenever I speak I try to set them
up separate Muslims from Islam I have an
opinion on Islam in the same way Islam
has an opinion up on me is Lama is
bigoted towards non-muslims not every
Muslim of course every every Muslim is
not big-eared if you if you've read my
book that some of the best meat people
I've met in my life growing up are
Muslims I don't have a problem of
Muslims but I do have a problem with the
way Islam is influenced in my country I
have a problem with the hatred is
incited from it and and we're on fearful
of what the future holds right so just
to be clear and this is what I've spent
a lot of the time on the show talking
about you're making a distinction
between Islam meaning the doctrine the
set of ideas that are in books between
that and between the people that may or
may not be using these ideas and as you
said you've met plenty of Muslim people
that you like a lot and you're making
that distinction
I made that distinction in a similar way
to the fact that look if I was a critic
of Scientology
I would not be getting called a racist I
would not be gang called any of the
things I am and just because it happens
a majority of non-muslims are not white
on beaten down and attacked with this
racist stick which is ridiculous because
Islam is an idea
it's an idea that should be criticized
and it's my god-given right to criticize
it yeah and I I don't incite how you
against individual Muslims I've never
ever there I let the English Defence
League for over six years I've never
been done for any racism
any extremism and he insightful speeches
in fact if people at the height of lead
in the English Defence League when there
was a when our soldier Lee Rigby was
beheaded in the streets of London our
very next demonstration I started my
speech off by saying that there are 600
Muslims who serve in the in the British
Armed Forces that if you attack a Muslim
woman or you get spear Muslim woman you
you're an absolute coward and I try to
get the distinction between some things
are morally just and I think
my campaign is morally just and
righteous and other things are cowardly
attack in the house is a worship whether
they be Christian or Muslim is cowardly
so from I've done that from day one in
fact as far as the organization goes
we've been a moderate voice in this in
this but we can put completely attacked
as extremists or hateful and inciting
hate literally just this week I've gone
with where we're having a demonstration
in the city of Birmingham which is
Britain's second biggest city hazard as
a large Muslim population it has a lot
of problems there and I met a Muslim
councilor and this is that this is where
the problem comes in and I said to him
if an organisation is completely
peaceful and there's no violence there's
no alcohol do they have a right to come
to this city and criticize Islam and he
said no and that's where we're at and I
said why not he said because criticizing
Islam incites hate said telling the
truth can't incite hey and and that's
where we're being beaten down so much
because so many and he he's a councillor
for the Labour Party which is a
mainstream political party true so many
people are against free speech when it
comes to Islam
yeah well as my audience knows I mean
this is really where the left has failed
and from everything that I'm hearing
from my friends in the UK and across
most of Europe sadly most of Western
Europe the left is failing everywhere
and the more that the voices of liberals
are silenced the more that the far right
is going to be strengthened you're
probably somewhat of an example of that
so before we get into all the specifics
and everything that's going on today can
you just tell me a little bit of your
history growing up when you became
politically active that kind of stuff so
I grew up in a town called Luton it's
one of the most multicultural towns in
Europe when I was born in 1982 there was
one mosque now there's in excess of 30
we have approximately 50 thousand
Muslims we've had just last week for
Muslims from my hometown one which went
went to my school have been charged with
terrorism
another young another Muslim who was a
white convert just again this this week
has been charged with inciting support
for Isis my hometown was the Lord
had for the 77 attack on London London's
underground the fertilizer bomb plot the
Stockholm bomber some of you men may
remember the Stockholm bomber he was
radicalized in my hometown he lived
doors away from my army right though
Alma's redeem you Oh mom Omar Bakri Abu
Hamza with the hook their head office
and their organization's base was in my
town so what's going on in that town
what's going on that sound is we've had
it's been the epicenter and the and the
home of radical Islam and they've been
allowed unchallenged by councils or
government or police for 30 years to
plan orchestrate and radicalize an
entire community and we've filled in my
hometown after September the 11th in
America when I come out to my shops the
next week we had magnificent nineteen
posters everywhere we had posters
glorifying the nineteen suicide bombers
that in the local college they
celebrated every year after that outside
in our town center there was a
celebration parade for the Muslims who
who murdered on September 11th that's
where I live so I've grown up from a
very young age and I have I have many of
these what we call liberals in the UK
they're not really liberals but or those
on the Left who condemn me
they shower me they and they know
nothing about the life I've lived
nothing could alter the life I've lived
they have not seen what we've seen they
don't live with the effects and when we
talk about multiculturalism in the UK
like we have our political leaders David
Cameron has come out and said
multiculturalism has failed Angela
Merkel said years ago Mori cultures and
espouse what they're actually saying
what they're actually saying is Islam's
failed because in my hometown and and my
group of friends the majority of them
come from immigrant background whether
it be solution Italian Bulgarian
Jamaican Indian and everyone gets on
fine and that an art my town has been
divided not through not through racial
lines ever we don't have the racial
problem at that I don't know if you I
believe you may have in the US but we
don't have a racial problem or that we
have a religious tensions and the
religious line drawn through the
communities right
so when you saw this growing up you know
you're not you're not that old right
you're in your mid-30s when did your
sort of awakening appear when did you
say okay this is something that I have
to talk about and attach myself to so my
awakening was the bezel M school
massacre 2000 and 2004 or believe it
what it was was that I'd watch this
group this group how much I mean I'd
watched them grow and when I say watch
them one of the man who's convicted this
week who was a next member of their
organization a wife ginger convert
called E Broome Hanson his name's Roger
really firm I'd watched him convert and
watch him become radical what seemed
some of my own friends who had converted
in prison and changed so I'd seen it or
I'd seen this group and then I watched
an interview after the bezler Massacre
where this group was saying in my
hometown that if it happened to an
English school it would be justified and
I also knew that that group were openly
converting and recruiting in my town
centre where my family go where we all
go they were openly recruiting on the
streets every single Saturday to send
people to fight for the Taliban against
our armed forces that was it for me that
was 2004 I organized my first
demonstration I was aged 21 years old
and I organized a demonstration called
ban the loot and Taliban so it's hard to
believe that so they're actually
recruiting in a town in England for the
Taliban we know that a lot of Isis
fighters are coming from England they're
coming from all of Western Europe
basically going through Turkey right
into Syria what what does
law-enforcement do about that it sounds
like that much right I do nothing I do
nothing so but what I did when I
organized this demonstration or I
actually made leaflets over ten years
ago now and in those leaflets well we're
going back 12 years so this was before
people have heard of homegrown terrorism
in the UK before people have heard of
these organizations and in the leaflets
I made a point that our daughters and
our sisters are being groomed which we
now know is an epidemic called grooming
which is where the groups of Muslim men
would get young girls and they
gang-raped them yeah and it's become an
epidemic across the UK yeah
it's been going on for 30 years no one's
ever spoke about it now 12 years ago I
made a leaflet which went on the front
page of my national news of my local
newspaper saying whites and blacks are
being religiously target our women are
being pimped and sexually abused and
prostituted by Muslim gangs I named the
Muslim gangs I named the extremist
organizations and I stood in the town
centre and read read this leaflet out
where I said that we demand that the
police act we demand that the council's
act um there was no action after that in
fact all that happened was I was
targeted I was targeted by Muslim gangs
yeah can some of the blame here be
blamed on something related to British
society that maybe we don't have here in
America America for all our faults and
we have plenty of racial problems and
all kinds of stuff we've done the
melting pot pretty well everyone has
come here no matter where they're from
and pretty much mixed in bringing their
traditions and then and then becoming
American it sounds like and from the
emails I'm getting from Denmark and
Sweden and all this that something has
happened in Europe but I guess
specifically in the UK where for
whatever reason the Muslim population
just hasn't integrated the way that
other immigrant populations have but
some of that beyond the fault of the UK
and not just the the Muslim population
yes it can yes it can be on the fault of
multiculturalists who encouraged all
these people to come here tell them that
their culture was equal to ours told
them that they can go back into their
own communities they can live as they
did in Afghanistan in Iraq and Pakistan
and as soon as anyone like ourselves try
to scratch beneath the surface to say
well let's see where we differ
culturally let's see where our opinions
differ then we've been screened down as
racists and the reality is we need to
understand and you say it's worked
relatively well in America you have
nowhere near the percent of Muslims in
comparison to Europe and it and it will
not work well in America and that's that
that's the warning you need to realize
is that you need to learn from what's
happening over here because you're going
to face the same problems if you ever
uneducated Somalians
coming in the uncontrollable numbers you
will face exactly the same problems I've
I've grown up with alou yeah yeah if you
allow if you allow Saudi Arabia you
allow Qatar you allow
you allow them foothold in your country
with salafists will harvest mosques you
allow them to build schools and teach
these children hatreds you will in the
next generation be experiencing the hey
that I experienced growing up so what do
you think a town like yours where it
this has been growing for a long time as
you're saying what should be done at
this point I mean these people are
citizens of the UK so what should be
done to fight these ideas not the people
but to fight these ideas that are
spreading what shouldn't be done is my
local council spend one hundred eighty
eight thousand pounds of taxpayers money
giving given to the Salafist mosque
that's a mosque that causes us huge
problem that that's a mosque that when
Ofsted went in into it they found books
in the children's school library for how
to carve hands and feet
we shouldn't be funding them we also
should not be allowing Saudi Arabia or
Qatar to fund these madrassas that are
popping up left right and center we
should be tough on on on so many issues
we it's knowing where to start really
and I think towns that haven't had the
problems at Luton have had should be
looking to our town looking at the
infiltration what we've seen is the way
the Muslims control themselves and the
way they vote then our local council no
longer care about us they don't care
because we don't keep them in power the
Labour Party are kept in power every
year in Luton by 30 to 50,000 Muslim
motors so we become irrelevant
and that's vote bank politics and we
don't vote based on someone's ethnicity
or we don't vote on basis someone
someone's religion but the Muslim
community do that's all they go yeah so
you know even as I'm talking to you I
have this feeling because I'm a liberal
I have this feeling of you know is he
exaggerating this like is this an act
you know how big is this problem you
know I follow you on twitter you tweet
videos all day long of you know women
being attacked either in the UK or in
Germany wherever and sometimes I have
trouble sort of figuring out how much of
this is actually happening all over the
place how big of the problem is versus
is it just this micro problem
and I guess I guess your answer would be
well it's a micro problem in my town but
it's it's spreading into this big macro
thing the problem is bigger than anyone
can comprehend and that's why the
political leaders that's why police
forces that's why it's now a fact in the
UK that police social workers councils
conspired to hide these facts but for
decades yeah can I go into that a little
bit because there's been a couple a
couple controversies about that yes so
there's been a rover M report and before
this Robin report people used to say I
was lying or inciting hate and I just
used to say it because it happened to my
cousin these similar sort of crimes and
we knew what the police reaction was
then so there was a Robin report an
in-depth report into one little small
town in the north of England in that
small town there's a population of male
Muslims that are aged aged between 18 to
40 there's about 3,000 now in that town
they identified 1,400 young English
girls who had been beaten prosecuted and
raped in unbelievable numbers some of
the girls were raped 30 times in one
night and when they've done this big
report what they found in the report
actually was the the council knew full
well the head of the police knew the
Muslim community knew everyone knew this
was happening but the reason why they'd
done nothing was through the fear have
been branded as racists that's how
powerful political correctness is now
two other circumstances in in this
report whether when the the police
turned up and there was a young girl who
was 11 years old and she's been raped in
a derelict house by five Muslim men now
when the police turned up they arrested
the girl for being drunk and disorderly
look you've got to read the report that
you've got to read the report and also
there's another circumstance where the
girl that got two of the girls who were
taken and these girls go missing for
days that 12 years old 13 years old 14
years old they go missing for days yeah
two of the girls were taken so the dads
went to get the girls back
the girls were inside the house the dads
have gone to the Muslims house to get
them back when the police turned up the
police arrested the English girls dads
they left the ghost and so these sort of
things which [ __ ] are your viewers
said that they sound unbelievable right
they sound unbelievable yeah they're in
a government report this is going on
across our whole entire country this
isn't just going on in our country it's
going on in Holland it's going on across
Europe look look at what's happening in
Sweden and this is comes from a mindset
and a culture and an ideology that
teaches them that Muslim Muslim not just
more women are inferior but not
non-muslim women like ours they're duh
no that's half
not all Muslims because some Muslims
I've grown up with would be as disgusted
as we are yeah but well there is a
problem if you look at the statistics
for these not not pedophilia because the
majority of pedophiles in the UK are
white which you'd expect from a 90%
white country this is a new new epidemic
that men share young children with their
brothers their cousins their work
colleagues that the level the viewing of
it within the community or within the
group is not viewed in the similar way
to how we would if a member of our
community said I've got this young 12
logo that you'd fill them in right but
this is something very very different
and it is new to the country and what
we're seeing now you've seen it with
cologne again with new easy it's now
been putting people's faces more than
ever
and we feel our I feel I've got two
young doors about two young doors we
have two I was just speaking before
about a professor who Angela Merkel was
giving a speech this week in a
university and the professor has stood
up and he's heckled her and he said I'm
scared I have children I have children
what what what future are you bringing
to our children this is an experiment
you know nothing about yeah and that's
the reality of it and it's not an
experiment we know nothing about we know
what's going to happen we we know what's
going to happen from case studies Luton
Town is a blueprint for the rest of the
UK it's a blueprint for the rest of
Europe it's a blueprint for America
what's happening here is happening
everywhere yeah I mean it's incredibly
chilling listening to you and again
that's why that's why I wanted to talk
to you and try to get a sense of the the
size of this whole thing I saw a video
this week did you see this a 16 year old
girl posted a video from Germany
talking about how she went to her local
supermarket and she saw these guys
staring at her and they they were
migrants and they were she really but
was afraid for her life she posted a
20-minute video on Facebook which she
clearly delineated she said I have
nothing against Muslim people she said I
have friends that are Muslim all of that
stuff she said these people these
specific people that are coming now
there's something different and from
what I understand the video was taken
down and she was at least temporarily
suspended from Facebook so that that
really shows you how perverse the
political correctness has got if now
Facebook is in on it too our Facebook's
completely on it yeah everyone keeps
getting suspended for for posting videos
or pictures of the reality and the truth
that young girl my that angers me so
much more than I can even express when I
watch that and I could well up in my
eyes sitting thinking she's not free to
walk to our shops in Germany in 2016 why
is she not free because hordes of hordes
of Muslim men are coming in from a
completely different culture a
completely different view on women a
completely different that's we have to
understand their mindset and what gets
me is that look I'm all for helping
refugees these are not refugees 60
percent 60 percent this week the EU
Commissioner has come out and said that
their economic migrants 60 percent
Angela Merkel has opened those borders
to one and a half million last year
there is gonna be a flood in the next
coming years of tens of millions of
Muslims coming to our coming to Europe
come into our continent where that girl
and her feeling is just gonna be natural
to everybody everybody's gonna be
feeling and we shouldn't feel fearful in
our in our own homes and towns and we do
right and we do and all we had all I
ever hear about is Islamophobia all we
ever hear about is that Muslim women are
scared I'm not being funny but not no
one's raped Muslim women no one is gang
raping Muslim women no young Muslim
girls were attacked on New Year's Eve no
Muslim has had their heads head cut off
in the street no this is not happening
to Muslims and that's and that's where
when we look at the target in our I had
a meet in this week um we've lead it
with a leading of a Sikh
take organization you should talk to
hear me he can give you real in-depth of
what's going on from a Sikh perspective
okay he deals with hundreds and hundreds
of young children who have been taken
from their families by Muslim gangs and
in the most recent one when I went with
a radio presenter and the radio percent
that said it's got nothing to do with
religion and he said well actually
everything they're saying to the girls
was rape is about religion yeah is the
religion or race I can go through the
court cases where there was a Somalian
Smyly and rape gang down in Bristol in
the UK and he actually said it was his
religious duty to do this it says really
and these are not what we're saying it's
what they're saying they're saying you
white trash you white filth will gut you
like a pig all of these comments are
being made to these young English girls
and all everyone wants to get around the
fact is oh every one's raping everyone
does it no not ninety percent the ninety
percent of the convictions for street
gang grooming are Muslim men now the
population of four percent well you know
I really am starting to see this as
almost the disease of the mind of people
on the left because even if even if
everything you were saying was being
magnified by 20 percent you know fifty
percent let's say you're totally
doubling the the severity of all of this
it's still a problem and every time I
hear my friends on the Left talk about
it they'll immediately say well you know
Christianity there were the Crusades or
the Catholic Church has covered up
molesting children for hundreds of years
all these things no one's denying those
things right and some of those things
are still happening right now yeah but
that doesn't mean that what you're
talking about isn't a problem so my
question to you is when in the UK did
the left go off the deep end you see
what I keep trying to say and I've tried
to save for six years now this is not a
left-wing or right-wing issue because
people will automatically pigeonhole
myself as right-wing or no actually
that's a lie I'm pigeon-holed as
far-right right
automatically whereas the majority of
people who have supported my
organisation over the years many of them
would have been left-wing labor voters
so to be clear the reason they'd be
left-wing is because there are four
women's
it's right and they're probably for gay
rights and and they're generally for
minorities so they should fit on the
left yeah yeah they're being pushed and
forced to the right yeah and that's
because the left in the UK politically
rely and have basically the Labour Party
in the UK then they're loyal vote bank
used to be working-class people like
myself yeah what we're in in England we
have a very classy system I don't think
you experience the same in America but
we have a very classy system at the
bottom and the top and yeah you have
ways fundamentally usually conservative
people were very wealthy and
working-class people are usually quite
poor
oh no not quite poor but poor and proud
anyway
but what we then see is that as as as
working-class people started doing
better
they would then aspire to be
conservatives because they get more
money yeah right so then it seems that
low but the Labour Party just completely
gave up on this but on this section of
the community and they went straight for
which tony blair is that government that
have have admitted bringing in loyal
voters which were immigrants which have
now become muslims there's one speech
where you can anyone come watch it his
name shall hit so he'd Matt Mallik and
he's a he was a Labour MP for Jewsbury
and in his speech he clearly tells us
saying in 2001 we had one Muslim MP in
2004 we had fruit three Muslim MPs in
2008 we had eight Muslim MPs and in
between saying each thing he says
inshallah inshallah inshallah
and he says within 15 years in this
country the majority of MPs will be
Muslim and then all the crowd which is a
thousand Muslims will cheer and clap and
then he says in in within 30 years the
prime minister of this nation will share
our faith yeah
now again I say don't listen to what I'm
saying yeah okay there's plenty of
Muslims telling and when he says this as
a representative for the Labour Party
this is the problem when you mix
religion with politics which is now
happening just it goes like this now
actually we have the Labour Party which
is the leading left-wing organization
when they have their meetings in Muslim
predominantly cities they segregate the
odd audiences they segregate the
audiences men and women in line with
Sharia
this is a party that's supposed to stand
up for women that's supposed to stand up
for gay people's Royces and that's why
I'm I have out of contempt and disgust
for what the Labour Party in the left
have now become but that doesn't mean
all left-wing people because Islam is
something that should concern and
especially the literal interpretations
of it shouldn't concern everybody on the
left and every liberal should be
screaming from the rooftops of what's
happening